[Music]
Nashville Tennessee how we building the
night
hello you do many now how you feel in
the night
thank you guys for coming down to the
live taping of the handsome Rambler pot
head make some noise for your co-host to
be trimmed in Hannibal Burres
[Music]
nice will thank you thanks for coming
through Tony how's it going man it's
going great
Tony didn't even speak he's a started
[ __ ] with wrinkles good good to see
you all
thanks for coming through how many
people listen to the podcast for a round
of laws that means they have no idea who
I am
yes that's a good amount of people that
listen but then that is the people that
don't listen they'll be really confused
cuz it was like especially when this
happens thank you all for coming to the
show man we got have a good time we're
here playing say knees this week's a
nice comedy club Nashville cities so
just getting off it's getting all
gentrified [ __ ] yes I'll justify a nice
I'm not I'm not I just lady was tryna we
parked in front of our air B&B I stepped
out of the car and I was kind of in
thought cuz he was about maybe four
thirty when we got here and I still need
to pick up a camera I was trying to plan
a show on my head now I was just you
know how to maybe my general blank
expression that I have on my face and
she said she said to me you just get to
Nashville smile look happier and I say
shut the [ __ ] up talking to me I got a
smile I don't think I don't think that's
nice
that's not nice to tell somebody usually
you just don't look at my face would
have [ __ ] you and I know she hate it
with dudes say that [ __ ] to her sauces
flippin and she just smiled [ __ ] out of
here it's like a low-key dish when
you're like you look tired you look he's
there smiling yeah she was like I
whipped my mom I said she should have
taught you better
talking to strangers telling them to
smile you don't know my life I should
have been like she smiled said about my
baby died yeah people always react to
stuff without knowing the hostess ways I
think I'm guilty of that just reacting
audiences do that a lot when I do a show
and sometimes I'll mention a city I'll
say I was in oh I was in st. Louis and
people just cheer that's because it not
used to here in st. Louis you don't know
the story I was about to say about st.
Louis yeah my brother could have got
murdered in st. Louis and you just
shared that this is a dark tone to the
pike as always talking about my
fictional baby died and my brother
getting murdered
all in five minutes people sitting on
the floor guys y'all relax okay this
blue room Third Man Records goddamn
and that antelope I don't know what it
looks a little too big to be antelope
but again what it uh it looks like an
African animal though for sure what is I
don't know who knows somebody has to
knows a spring wet a spring but the [ __ ]
didn't even know that animal existed
till now it's okay though I didn't know
that existed I think he lied
I think he's a goddamn liar I'll take
his word for it well this is uneven we
sound SEC for about 45 minutes and I
didn't notice that at all and I wish I
noticed it doing sound set because I
would have got all my thoughts of it
about it out of my system and now I feel
like it's really God take over the show
[Music]
what type of day
what we do Grabavoy
wise
what the [ __ ] is that Hannibal still
even though the song had had a clear
ending my thoughts about that but our
power throw and welcome my first guest
to the stage good friend he's tour with
us right now
he has his own Paul cut Paul yes zone
podcast called the ball hawk please
welcome Kevin Boltzmann yes well
[Applause]
[Music]
something like that when I was delivered
at birth
nice this is supposed to be the doctor
nice work man
nice work hey man you know we we
sporadically get together and we hang
out in bunches it's because I I'm
getting old I'm the oldest of the group
I'm 47 I don't hide that I'm killing it
40s it's amazing and but I find myself
hating people more and more people out
of [ __ ] worse especially ones with
thoughts and opinions what that's why
that's why I gotta hang out with people
that I like what what did I enjoy
because other people are the worst
probably people in this audience there's
probably people like I'm glad they're
here but I not I wouldn't try to hang
out with them here's the thing like we
remember like when you were younger like
people like when you get older you get
wise or you'll learn tolerance you won't
but what you will learn is to stay away
from [ __ ] you can't tolerate
and though the two different things same
result like I was younger all I would do
is argue now I'm like I'm never gonna
speak to you ever again and it's great
so like we we're here we chill out we
sit in a house a week we go to barbecue
joints keV I take that as a compliment
cuz all we've been doing is debating no
you know I almost choked you out last
night that's different
know him and I was arguing about pizza
on the way to the air
be on the way back we argued about
burgers I mean but it's bacon we started
with pizza and then we went to burgers
and then we were talking about putting
bacon on burgers and I'm totally anti
that I just I think bacon is overrated
that's and then we got into it no no no
no this what he said we we were arguing
I was like you can put bacon on
everything man makes it delicious baked
is overrated man but bacon fat you could
put that in anything same goddamn thing
tone thank you Zach here's the argument
though for bacon face here's a full of I
fried up over cooking a versus bacon you
like let me get this bacon threads he
sassy suck-ups
cooks the bacon throws the bacon away
and then uses the bank attack
what kind of monster yes your life like
that let's guy so much it's amazing
right here between this and whatever
that is on the wall I'm overwhelmed
right now but it's it this this [ __ ]
your bacon fat story same thing on the
wall and the fact that captain's hat
matches his microphone it's flared up
they say this is what happens when God
brings you out we got breezed out of the
womb you had sometimes they match your
microphone all right I wouldn't even say
that uh your stands with bacon fat is
polarizing I would say your one against
yeah okay so let me allow me to explain
my sleeves okay so if bacon was sell
sold in the jar it's just a jar of fat
nobody would eat it with a spoon that's
disgusting
but if you use it as cooking oil it's a
delicious oil but just eating the bacon
I did that doesn't do for me like a nice
steak or a sausage
okay listen man we understand that bacon
isn't steak
no one's rapping yeah and why are you
talking to us like that no one is trying
to wrap their schlep around a piece of
[ __ ] filet mignon we play in that but
you know we've talked they're only
people you see that
[Music]
I'm a rare with the Moz you it just it's
just fat around little piece of meat is
overrated to me that's that wasn't my
point but right but the same fat you
can't go without when it's time to cook
with it I can't decide exact can't go it
out of you sleep that shouldn't
everything you cook some kale with it
it's delicious but just eating pieces of
bacon just spread those the last she
went to the store and bought a side of
bacon fat do they sell that yeah they do
actually where when you get like we its
top layer is like bacon fat it's just
straight-up fat like pork rillette
straight let's not get into this bacon
but that bacon is like so with it to
cook with it
yeah it's like saying you like lands
bears but you not a Backstreet Boy right
whatever you get what I'm saying I'm a
complicated man
hearts are greater than the whole man
I'm a complicated man you know sometimes
you know like sometimes I don't want to
eat a bunch of peanuts but I'll cook
something in peanut oil because it makes
it taste better because a funeral it's
ridiculous dinner it's like saying you
ought to know you ought to know your
favorite song ever but you can't stand
Alanis Morissette can't stand that [ __ ]
man everything she stands for I'm a
guest but you ought to know that's my
favorite song ever
hey Tony Tony get him analysis because
emotions just champagne and orange Paul
I'm glad I hit he was so confident in
the car and I just like oh I can't wait
to bring this [ __ ] up tomorrow so 150
people can look with you with
disappointment
I know people love their bacon I can't
argue with with people's love for bacon
can't argue with people fact
well I cook with it this is what I'm
saying uh you know I'll use it to play
the bacon we talked about bacon on the
cheeseburger and you lost your [ __ ] I
don't like this you lost your [ __ ] I
think making all the cheeseburger
Bozeman man that says I'm just talking a
regular burger we're not talking all
that crazy [ __ ]
everyone was bacon yeah everyone wants
bacon cuz that is how much Americans how
much you don't like my burger to be a
burger you put cheese on it as a
cheeseburger you see what I'm saying no
I just like it cuz you you like bacon
cuz you could get with bacon fat you
make it you just Sam it tastes like
bacon is [ __ ] look at this bacon sautéed
spinach spinach when I'm average I don't
want I don't want to have sex but if you
could just squeeze your [ __ ] juice out
put it in a cup
[Laughter]
[Music]
squeeze the [ __ ] juice out I'm sorry
what if you want only squeeze
the procedures for me
just curious what you plan on doing with
it I want you to put it in the five okay
what I'm gonna do
I use the [ __ ] juice as pennies for up
straight to ten now ten minutes to bake
and I put it in one of those they hit
you steak tastes funny
this risotto takes we're what do you
what do you put it mad to give us flavor
[Music]
[Music]
is it did no I guess not because I guess
I would know the answer to that is it
the sauce or the spices or sauce the
sauce and spice day am I right or wrong
this is a dry rub right is it so is it
fried chicken with spices yeah
everything it's ungodly highs this is
this is what you came here for to sell
us on your hot chicken
you guys like it well the hot chicken
can I get a consensus from Nashville
people because an uber driver told me
that like the hot hot chicken like the
hottest is like a hoax for tourists
[ __ ]
I just want to over driver told me out
here they said they said nobody eats
that [ __ ] that's four tours make them
cry or whatever but I don't get the
purpose of the really really hot one
they're like the hottest I can't
yes
Friz the hottest of the hat was the
point I tried it hurt a lot
and they even forgetting that you ate it
and you touch your eyes yeah yeah yeah
you take a piss does anyone ever
experienced that
so you can get it from from anywhere
like was just a specific place go to
princess bar princess what pepper fires
patty beans that's the name of the place
no that's the name of a juvenile yeah
man well you talked about taking a piss
it made me think about back in 2008 when
in a moment of weakness in my apartment
in Chicago at the table in my kitchen
[Music]
you never told me this I tried to jack
up for instance that's a terrible
lubricant I know this disappears just
best that's like basically dipping your
hand a bottle of Jameson and just
getting the game
yeah well I've realized right away
immediately I realized here with my ways
it was terrible yeah somebody just gasps
mystery you stopped drinking
we got a poison him some other way yeah
it's just been I've been really into
candy lately because your body when you
drink a lot of liquor sugar or your body
converts into sugar and I don't have
that alcohol sugar I just going crazy in
the candy aisle I'll spin I'll be in a
candy aisle shop it with my arms folded
like I'm looking at cars
no no to get a tree sealer for Aziz how
do sour patch kids - well every season
oh maybe I get the custom sound best kid
with the two-tone I have just in there
for a wild man it's a mess
yeah not today cuz I was like cuz
there's already recesses in the freezer
I was gonna eat one Kevin's like nah
that's
Hannibal's and then this mofo comes back
with two king-sized four packs of
Reese's like what's with all the Reese's
you smoke cigarettes you're addicted I'm
addicted [ __ ] you did you did have a
bunch of gummy bears on the way here but
the gummy bears wasn't open like a
normal person it was all split open and
it was just gummy bears crawling out the
bad you didn't this like tear it off it
just reach for a couple like you you
have to make sure that you grab a
handful that's not that's not right
again
you went through the bag and yet like
throwing like butterfingers a Reese's
peanut butter cups around the get to
this bag of gummy bear so yeah man yeah
I planned it out - that's how much I am
in the kid why I bought the
butterfingers the Reese's Cup and the
gummy bears and we're driving from
Memphis and I was like okay we just ate
some barbeque in Memphis and probably
about in an hour and a half mark got a
drive I'm gonna eat the gummy bears and
then when we get to Nashville I'm a
follow up with the Reese's Cups right I
don't know if you aware it is is that
the older black man to a younger black
man diabetes is a thing with us so I
just I just thought you might want to
know that but sure the guy that made
three gas station stops last night for
M&Ms
he make it seem like I went to East gas
station and bought [ __ ] M&Ms you see
how combative this [ __ ] is all
the gas stations were closed and then I
found one I got one bag of M&M you may
see like I stopped there I won't be none
in Mineo this was the peanut butter but
we had to make three stops it's like you
got to give up up to the freedom to make
three stops bike that driver was just
nice enough to stop cuz we need that
[ __ ] going on dude I'm talking about
what tolerance you me and Kevin ever
love-hate relationship this mostly love
until you start giving us your opinions
[Music]
[Laughter]
Tony yes sir you you talking about you
doing martial arts but I believe you
because I'm Asian no I gotta go to come
fool class where's this come for class I
mean I don't know let's get an audience
volunteers let Tony beets [ __ ] out of
you that's the issue this that's good
stuff
we're bad as segments for the pike yeah
the same here's the next segment
finalist in a public forum this is a
mrs. Jack white spot that white he was
uh he was he did interview he was asked
what does TJ count it does I know what
these accountant does you know what
these are counted does you know what
he's good at
he know P like some people you email
them asking for something hey man can
you uh give me that first can you give
me that that drop that recorded and if
they don't reply you just leave it alone
dj khaled is a guy that says the email
just says following up
and if you don't flatter the emailer
says follow it up he says another words
so basically he's annoying
he's not a noise persistent and he
brings people together to do [ __ ] you
know he's a master of branding I'll give
him that but I do feel I do agree with
Jack White but as far
you can't deny him on branding he's a
branding master he's good that's our
president got to where he's at Brendan
branding no yes
Trump is a master at branding well a
little bit obsessed man I think he's a
good guy I'm not sticking up for the guy
just saying he knows how to brand a
great great again I mean the racist
stuff yes it's racist branding I wonder
if there's people that are liberals that
still stay out of trouble - OH
what [ __ ] man this is all the place I
could use my hotels calm free night
I don't I don't think that's where I
take a stand that's why I take a stand
when I search it for hotels and I see a
Trump Hotel with a list even if it's
five star in my head I say I don't even
eat McDonald's anymore because of trauma
what what's Trump gonna do with that
that [ __ ] East McDonald's
everyday everyday daily hey quarter
pounder with cheese diet coke that's his
thing
I just know sometimes I don't know where
did you get this information it's there
it's out there yeah
you said I trust the Internet he loves
quarter-pounder with cheese and diet
cokes so I don't I feel like in a few
months
a record is gonna link up Trump said I'm
so scared
yeah I got no one else to blame man I
blamed everybody fired you should have a
limit of people you fired from the
cabinet and then you can't be president
anymore I broke every now I read out
every B's in Chicago and if you cancel
three different guests reservation in a
year they take you off Airbnb MPB as
tougher rules than a United States
government
again that's branding though you're
fired
[Music]
that's branding LTS Brandon I think he's
is taken though I'm as the guy that
fires people yeah but he's taking it too
far
maybe we should kick some freestyles or
lighten that up
[Music]
okay I'll be shy I like I like I win
experience as well somebody did
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm getting into this [ __ ] yeah that's
just sound [ __ ] it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's good yeah yeah wouldn't be funny to
only do stand-up on like live pod cut
like that you know how were usually do
we do late night shows right so you can
be like a late night comic that just
doesn't and you're like just a been in
the future there will be a comic that's
maybe not even born yet
that will only perform on live parties
it's all he does is he goes out does
that leave just do a little bit in the
middle interviewing the Obama he just
starts with you and then I'd rather to
get to Obama and then you're like and
then you have to change moods all right
or maybe not guys I don't know it's
probably too early if y'all even wrap
your head around that's how this is what
I'm starting to book his comics to do
podcast I'm too far ahead of the game
everybody's like I don't think it's
gonna work you're Pioneer I believe this
is only begins no I don't boycott
anything I will do whatever anybody if
you're a successful company I don't care
what you're doing so if you're
in my life and I'm gonna have to like
it's literally adjust something pretty
big out of my life and you're there do
whatever you want to do you can shoot at
my family and I would probably get over
it I would be like well you know we
still have to fly to Atlanta and it's an
easy flight yeah that's that's pretty
insane if you're gonna boycott that's
the time to in there like I don't even
know how people were like yeah that's
fine
like who everybody's just sitting there
and being like your dogs they're going
the thing at the top and then you're
like I don't know if that's you don't
let me put a lot of bags up there I
don't know why she'd oh wait how did
that at the moment like you can't put a
dog up there yeah hi why didn't nobody
speak up at that moment yeah how
airtight are those two I didn't think
they were that like it's the real deal
yeah I don't know it seems weird that
they sometimes I feel like something had
to be kind of weird in that situation
cuz I don't see how everybody on that
plane would be like that's you can't do
that you mind excuse me this is the
middle seat when you go up there to get
your laptop could you also look over
there at the dog and see if the dog
stole who's that monster just like look
I keep the dogs up there and steer the
story should have been United tried to
make me put my dog was in shame I put my
dog why would I not you know like unless
you were flying for the first time the
person that was okay with putting the
dog up there what did his died of a
heart attack or something right here's
the reality of it man people
you points and miles interesting you got
a lot of points built up people you will
let people mistreat you because you
don't want to lose your points you so
that person's like close to a free
flight they're like alright put the dog
up there but you're not gonna ruin this
trip to Orlando with my family people do
want to just go to like they don't want
anything to mess up a flight like your
dear like just go they could I mean when
you're on the ground they could like one
of our engines is not working you're
like I think we can do it with just like
here you can wrap your head around that
log in the air you would lose your mind
but like I mean there's stuff that
breaks on planes it's like the bathroom
won't work or something someone is
talking about in their lover like just
fly anyway and you're like well that's
probably a big deal and then they should
get stuff fixed but people are just I
know the bathroom is much different than
an engine I don't think bathrooms fly
airplanes I don't know yeah I think
that's the level intelligent I'm at like
this is a bathroom has a lot more to do
than you think with an engine of a plane
and you notice two on those sides in the
bathroom they make it look like if you
flush like a tampon down there it'll
ruin everything there like causes
serious leaks it might [ __ ] up the plane
if dudes had tampons we would never not
flush it down like I would hope that
most women just do it anyway because
that's I don't know where you're
supposed to I've never looked into all
that yeah but I know do it just because
you do you buy the tampons adjust the
flushing yeah
second keep the economy going never buy
some adjuster feel ya I'm perhaps but I
suppose buys our impulse buy tampons and
mints I think an impulse buys are there
I don't think that's a good enforcement
I feel like impulse buys are supposed to
be something else
you have somewhere difficulty they are
clearly very different than most nobody
tell you that I don't think most
people's our mitts and ample an economy
size bag of gummy bears as an impulse
buy that wasn't an impulse buy that's it
was thought through I looked at it I
paced around and I looked at energy
drinks I said let me take some time away
from this make sure I'm not making a
rash decision and then I circled back
around looked at the gummy bears again
and then I made my decision you know
yeah I decided I decided to put the do I
want American my house don't want United
miles with his uh these gummi bears
what you know if when I go with Delta
Southwest miles what would Delta foot of
miles because they haven't killed any
puppies lately that I know what they
might just have a better PR cleaner than
we're not supposed to fly American
anymore apparently racist I know I can't
do it they they accuse some one of the
flight attendants accused us
Geely NBA players are still in blankets
and pillows and first-class that make
any money in the jeely either you don't
make any money like that's like yeah
isn't that well they make more alright
I'm gonna get in sports argument but
we're talking about Gigi Lee he is
baseball finally finally
let's guys you know it used to be the
d-league Developmental League and they
changed it to G League for Gatorade I
think it sounds better to be in now yeah
it's the G League for Gatorade Wow and
it's better when you tell your family
what you're in that's funner to say I'm
in the jeely it's like Gatorade you know
that's a better thing to say you get the
NBA socks though that's a socks you get
the NBA socks you know you know I found
out it's pretty easy to declare yourself
eligible for the NBA Draft and I'm I'm
doing it this year thank you thank you
by the way process it's just paperwork
it's just users have to fulfill the
requirements which is you have to be at
least 19 at least one NBA season has has
to pass in between you being in high
school and declare for the draft which
I've what 18 of those and you got today
now we the thing they're safe he's had
the most seasons passed between high
school and NBA so that's why I think he
has a chance you've been working on your
game for 18 years and you just do the
paperwork because there's college
basketball players that don't get
drafted every year so I'll just be one
of those without he should take my life
the basketball can you get into like
wherever they do it the garden or
wherever they do the draft where you get
to watch the guys get drafted
that's invite-only you should get at
least buy a ticket I can get it to you
get the draft go sit so these thinking
because no doubt that you can get into
the drought yeah there's a lot of doubt
that you can sit with those players to
actually get drafted at I was a
spider-man
which is something else they bring up
when they show his report of watches why
why he could be a good fit for a team at
the most years he was in spider-man were
you inspired me I don't think you were
when I was in spider-man you
[ __ ] will be in seventeen the
new the New York Knicks select Peter
Parker's high school high school gym
teacher
hello bers you know helpful likes that
like insert himself into like
professional sports I mean recently
was it the Invicta fight it fit to fight
yeah you had your face all over them I
had my face and so I sponsored some
fights so it is Invicta Invicta is all
women's MMA and and they so like the
best of Invicta end up fighting in UFC
which is the biggest mixed martial arts
promotion so it's like cyborg she
started in in Victor and his UFC so last
year I went to an event and I it was in
Kansas City and it's really exciting but
it's super intimus like a thousand see
his venue and they had these sponsors
and I was seeing all these banners with
these sponsors i Kansas City Toyota and
and some dentists and you know some
dentists in Kansas City Toyota can
sponsor fight it like a sponsor fight it
and so I reached out sponsor a fighter
so how do i sponsor a fighter and they
reply to my email seven minutes later
it was amazing and they sent me to they
sent me to the the card for the next
fight and I picked this one fighter from
Brazil and we sent her an outfit to have
my face all over it
it was [ __ ] will here my website on
the waistband it's like an all-over
print of his she did promos he did she
took pictures in it and I was very
excited great
goddamn sponsor fighter you know it was
I was excited cuz even if she lose is
hilarious I just hope she falls on her
back Oh falls on her stomach so then you
know my website to be there said
whatever but this she missed weight and
didn't fight yeah she miss weight and
didn't fight and then I reached out to
her management to say hey case in that
outfit back and he said no we can't send
it back Cesar we took pictures in it so
then I was very I was scarred by the
experience that's how they get that's
how they get yeah takes a couple times
you're gonna get a couple they're gonna
miss wait that's part of the game you
wanna get in the ocean as soon as you
miss await somebody in the back was like
god yeah but I didn't pay the
sponsorship money I just paid for the
clothes so it said that was about a year
ago and so I kept on thinking about
sponsor another fighter but I was I was
feeling I was on it scarred by that
experience and so I was I was thinking
about doing it again for these fights
and I didn't want to take that risk with
sponsor and one fighter so I just asked
them I said how much is it to just put
my face on the canvas and they email me
back three minutes later and they told
me how much it was and I PayPal them
right away
[Laughter]
there was that place you have a new
fight coming up the fight this fight was
uh this past Saturday this Saturday in
Salt Lake City and my face was all it's
all watch the fight is so people they
were getting the [ __ ] beat out of him on
my face I saw pictures on Twitter
there's just like I saw one that was it
was just bloody and you see animals face
just like you know just trying to have
fun you know that's what you do that's
what you do with you thirty-five without
a family you just spend your money on
exciting experiences to fill the hole
yeah found out a little bit the ref had
to it fell off the brink pulse it was a
good time watch it so if you want to get
into the fight spine yeah I think that
seems I always think that but I think
buses bus bus stops seems like they
forget about them I think if you get on
the right time they're eventually just
forget about that and then you could be
on there forever that you want coming
out to see you know the bus stop yeah
yeah I want the people driving by going
I would never be riding that bus and
then they see that but their neighbor
gets he's gonna be in town those are
probably because you're looking right at
it when you're pissing about the biggest
fight I picked a Planned Parenthood I
would want my face to be in a Planned
Parenthood y'all want to hear some some
high [ __ ] you know advertising is the
only thing that uses advertise
advertises sales advertised by
advertisers
it's like it better cause they always
say you you could be here you lookin at
this [ __ ] aren't you
you can have your [ __ ] here instead of
us trying to sell you are trying to be
here you could sell other people on you
yeah here's the number call us we'll put
you right here and they're doing it but
they they're doing it for free
essentially unless they're paying are
they find themselves are they painted
are the store I paid I think I just
figured my own question out in front of
everybody hard they're paying the
building that they're in I paid me to
tell you about me come see me and then
it'll make it worth it for me but you
gonna like this - that's he would go but
when that guy first came in to business
was like I want advertisers I got what's
your business it's not I'm advertising
let people know if they can advertise in
your business you don't mad you would be
that guy they do the worst and then he
would eventually it catch on though yeah
now look at him he's doing real good
ever that guy is I assume it's one guy
for everyone but he's killing it do you
remember I was working to ruin some
Prince's chicken yeah here yeah we went
about 340 I wasn't I've been lived here
in that back home for three so before I
moved back and we went you were in town
I forget briefly and I was here and I
was at my parents we went to Prince's
you know I've actually never been there
even though I'm from here just never did
it and then we go and it was yet to pay
cash only right I didn't have cash so
then hand want to pay for mine and then
told me he's like bout to get back from
you whenever and I was like hand well
I'm never giving you this money back I
I'll never know how much it was I still
owe him buzz I'll never give it to you
all right I think I told you do your fat
girl I'm not paying for you Janey's is
all sold out the handle was pretty big
at this point he was in spider-man
I'm like I'm not gonna hunt you down see
maybe maybe ten dollars at the most and
then we mean I see so many behind the
music's where people just if you get to
that point I will give you that ten
dollars back and if I see you on a vh1
and it's not going good
I'll call you hey here's that ten
dollars Hannibal is gonna be like a man
remember I got you starting with that
live podcast comedy show we win it but
as funny as they went in and you got
your food and I never got mine you do
you remember they they saved they gave
you yours right away you sit down you
ate they told me mine was coming
never came until the very end and we had
to go and I had to get it to go oh yeah
the soul yeah and then I took it home
right what another part that's great
there's no staying at my parents I left
I couldn't really gonna eat it because I
had to leave I was leaving someone and
so I left it there my dad came home and
ate it he didn't know what he was he
just assumed it was regular chicken and
so ate it like you would eat it regular
chicken and then just lit him up yeah I
mean engines and they're imagining that
hot chicken without and I mean you just
you're going in like I'm eating regular
chicken so you can't tell that it's it's
not like that no no I mean it's just
chicken yeah they say that [ __ ] at all
yeah but God held that held that out
without it just looks like regular [ __ ]
just so yeah so it's all spice the hot
chicken is more the burners more like
after birds yeah like when you bite into
it it's not it doesn't hit you right
away so after you swallow you're like
goddamn what the [ __ ] did I just yeah
like you feel it after you swallow okay
it's so good so does it that he called
you no he just told me about it I mean I
like I don't know if there's so much
more to the story so don't go through a
ton of questions okay
it's a
so how is your relationship with your
father do you think that it's a with
about the chicken thing that started a
lot of vents and he told the truth after
that when it's like the Wonder Woman
will let's see the last up I don't know
that worked out of work if I were to get
it out immediately instead of just
dragging out so how long did you live in
New York almost nine years nine years we
I moved in because we met in Chicago
yep where we both started I started
they're brand new
I moved there in o2o3 is when I started
stand-up and then I moved in Oh for like
middle of Oh forth to New York and then
I started I did with Pete Holmes on
crashing I barked at the Boston Comedy
Club with Pete so that and that's how I
and then Pete was there and then you
came when did you come
New York 2006 for a little bit in 2008
it was a pretty wild group that was in
Chicago that all of us starting yeah
like me not saying me but like you
Kumail TJ Miller Pete Holmes
Kyle Kinane just left when I started our
may be outed like just missed him but it
was a pretty wild group and then we
moved then we all went to New York and
then you came to New York and was
homeless yeah
oh good time that's when I would have
given you that I would have given you
that ten dollars at that point I would
have said we should give him ten dollars
yeah and you uh then start out you'd
sleep I think you fell see that open mic
and just go put mics and just kind of
nod I don't know if these I mean they're
open mics they are pretty bad I mean it
is you watch it 30 over my comedians
[ __ ] fall asleep it's uh I feel like
it's - it's like the setting - because
it was like five o'clock it's like you
just don't as it in New York Comic you
just didn't have anywhere to go
you know you're just like sitting there
waiting till the next one starts right
so you would just sit
and wait till the next one and then go
to the next one and it was so many acts
over mic they should not 40 comedians on
what 40 comedians on one show and
Lincoln Lodge that's just I was at
Lincoln lodge or not Lincoln lunch the
one that shut down the longest-running
open mic and I was did instead Lions Den
in wood it would be 80 I mean it would
be it was insane you and you wanted to
be 30 you wanted to be in the 30 group
that was the good group to be like that
was when actually people would walk in
but you would sign if you're one you
might as well kill yourself and if
you're a hundred you could go watch four
movies and come back and it's not like
there's still 20 more yeah that was some
that was they would get some audience
that we can see maybe get a nice a crowd
I would I tell people all the time if
you want to do stand-up like you're not
supposed to make it and stand up you are
supposed to fail at this you could put
in all the hours that you want but you
are supposed to fail this is a hard job
to talk to people and no one else says
[ __ ] and then people be like hey here's
some money for that thank you
yeah thank you for being the only one
that's talking that what a talent my
wife just told me that like she goes
it's weird that you go and talk to
someone and no one else talks back to
you just said that just fifteen years of
doing it yeah and it just hit her that
she's like when you really think about
it it is real weird that you're talking
and no one else's there's no interaction
no one's like oh yeah that's cool man
you know what's going yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's just you just talking if
somebody said I see were you coming from
you like a make shut the [ __ ] up
would you don't disrespect me that way
you [ __ ] with my brother
how many traceless is mercenary
supporting you but not too much silence
but laugh don't laugh like crazy but
laugh I've seen people if you see people
get kicked out for laughing whether
everyone you know I got kicked out
because we were laughing too hard this
club's our [ __ ] we're never coming
back that's what happened
what's so sometimes it shows is so funny
were you doing the show and there's all
types of [ __ ] happen that happened in
the room that you find out about after
the show well you've been at you and
you're so you think you're kind of aware
and you proceed you use you see in
everything in after the showed you talk
to me they said yeah there was a fight
in the background and one dude threw up
and we put out about eight people like
that was going on that was going on
while I was talking about Charlie
Chaplin any feel just a little you feel
thought you like mean it feels a little
wall I'm just going onstage like
something's not it's not going to bad so
you don't want to wreck your set Billy
what's going on then they're like
nothing you're just not good yeah but
then you do sometimes I asked I was a
nice in Chicago once in Canaan was
headlining and I was just there and I'm
in the back and a fight broke out in the
very back and zany's is a very long room
you can't really tell when you're on
stage what's going on in the back and I
mean it is a straight-up like and I was
like kind of I got caught back there by
him and there some guys would just talk
too loud the guy said be quiet that ends
up being a fight they stand up there in
each other's faces I mean it's a full-on
it's basically like two different events
are happening in the same building if
the guy and the guy was a undercover cop
all right he was not undercover B was
just like out and about but he was a cop
maybe wasn't no he was he really doing
good job he brought his family to his
esteem he was like that's how undercover
I go I bring my regular family out
that'd be a good time to do is another
cover cop if you're like they bet your
speech to get into undercover cop stuff
is to go out go out with my regular
family infantry and infantry race my
daughter to this casino I don't have met
I uh
I once I did a show and after the show I
do came up to me as oh why do you here
to me is like sorry man I didn't mean
that and I was like I didn't but I
didn't know what happened so I go ain't
man some do just apologize to me what
happened Oh II screamed out speak up
[ __ ] and then you didn't hear him I
was like oh alright
I'm just glad you were me I know you
were trying to help love what you say so
that guy still does that it's you it's
on you you gave that guy you like that
wasn't that bad
oh man I should the black dudes hand man
he said it was all good people always
apologize when they come up and uh asked
me for a picture but they do it in this
way they say sorry I'm a piece of [ __ ]
can you take a picture with me sorry to
be an [ __ ] I hate to be that guy can
I take a picture with you you you talked
me out of it it's like I hate I hate
being that person but I'm gonna be that
person that's gone I think that was the
first first one that people started
saying that it was like you were saying
it to think I'll just be I'll be cool
now everybody's saying that so then
you're like well now it's not original
anybody is who that is everybody
nobody sorry at all what
what a what do i what like starting a
sense like I don't want to sound racist
but what's that I remember it at the
Georgia this was playing 41 and it was
during daytime and I was uh I was I was
on bumble yeah I was trying to something
I like to try to if I'm if I'm trying to
get something I try to get some pre-show
hook up cuz after the show that's cliche
everybody could do that but get laid at
3 p.m.
that's Pro time right there good strains
at 3 p.m. that's tougher then after the
so everybody's around yeah that's
[ __ ] t-ball right there ok 3 p.m. is
fast pitch got damn curve balls right
there
you gotta keep your eye on and so this
girl she comes through and you know we
we make love 3 and 3 p.m. we have a
sweet sweet love sweet love sweet Athens
love she kiss ready to leave the hotel
rope and she said can I take a picture
with you really no get out
but if you can't do Paul's [ __ ] up
selfies do a/c but it can't do both
either do the selfie and no [ __ ] or
[ __ ] and no selfie not a package deal
did you did you give her those options
when she came in take something happen
for you to learn and so now I noticed
that boundaries it'd be nice if you
actually had like a brochure he'd be
like oh I'm sorry but if you look here
the packages were available yes we don't
have this we don't have don't have
[ __ ] and then selfie package yeah we
don't have it inside please do not take
any pictures of me while I'm sleeping a
couple times I feel it though I feel it
that they is something about them I read
before they go I act like I'll say give
me a phone I put my number in there and
then and then I'll see a picture of me
sleeping pieces with the hell is wrong
with you you probably eat bacon fat no
bacon you piece of [ __ ] you should text
don't get out you should text them now
that they have your number you know I
think you just got a text and they read
it and says get out cause if they ask
you're gonna say no afterwards we've
already learned that that girl's told
everybody else don't ask just do it when
he's asleep because if you ask he makes
it a whole thing and then he says you
should have chose picture of this which
was not a real choice take that no one
ever get that far it go before we do
this I want a picture but if that's
going to stop this picture I don't want
to go as far and then you're gonna be
reasonable and go well that's a
reasonable thing to say I'll take a
picture with you thanks for asking
[Laughter]
raishin that you would have to be you're
gonna go that's an honest warlike
picture if this picture is gonna ruin
our sex tan I mean I'm just cool with
the picture if that's it yeah you start
getting more of that your bumbles just
that just pictures its way nightmare
she's a mess damn how what I was trying
to get to it's good it's good
it's yeah it's unbelievable we yeah we
both don't live in major cities are like
the typical New Yorker yeah and I but I
might like well I love it I think it's
uh you get a better I don't know we're
talked about even like material for
everything you just you can someone
you're doing a normal life you're not
around the comics all day or feel like
you're talking about the business all
day which is a good thing
yeah yeah thank so it's not like I know
like it's not like I'm like yeah my tax
stuff that wasn't ya know I'm from here
so that's that was the decision but that
did work out I would assume I still have
it it's not like I'm sitting here going
like it's gotten real good nobody my
parents want my parents whether moved to
Knoxville know why the [ __ ] you want to
move out there and they're like Texas
man
that's the NBA players that's a that's a
thing that some of them Miami why Miami
is such a destination is taxes and I
mean a being Miami but like NBA players
can choose people will pro athletes go
somewhere because how much money they
will save yes they make these crazy
contracts and save all sports athletes
as sanity live in Florida Derek Jeter
lived in Florida went straight from
Kalamazoo to food right because he's
from Kalamazoo Michigan but the whole
time he's with the Yankees he always
said Florida Texas
I don't know Wyoming's tax situation
you've been a Wyoming before I think I
have I've been everywhere except Alaska
and North Dakota he hasn't been to any
other Dakotas either yeah my out of the
50 I've only haven't been in North
Dakota South Dakota West Virginia and
Wyoming see that's you know why that's
because you guys are way more successful
to me I've been in North Dakota and
South Dakota a lot so I get those emails
with those gigs where there are there
there be offering like $100 no hotel
somewhere in Wyoming you're like this is
I don't know who could take this gig
like who could be like perfect that
lines up like I don't know I mean you
would have to be the guy that there's a
guy's son that's running the show to be
like nice I'm actually gonna make some
money tonight to get that gig to work I
opened for there was a guy I didn't show
West Virginia yeah and the one of the
worst shows ever done I mean I should
drive our car out of car in New York and
it was registered in Nashville so we
have Marta which you have to go get your
car checked every year see we'd have to
drive it down from New York
and so when I'm driving I would always
do like these gigs these like weird
one-nighters those types of gifts and
you know you make $100 but it paid for
that so I've gone to West Virginia
I do this gig it's in a dance club
that's got a lock on it in order to get
in you had a buzz so it's a real loud
buzz so when and like and that's because
it was like you couldn't just they
couldn't let people just walk in there
because it's how insane it was and so I
me and this other guy you're on and I
don't know that guy is we're doing the
show it's supposed to be a dance club
after us so they're like kind of walking
in no one's watching the show they're
just coming to Danny's and they're just
sitting there and we're just having to
stand like in the middle of them as
they're like excuse me and then they
walk by us to go sit at the table just
to wait how long is it you see them
start like how long is this gonna be and
I remember I brought the guy up that
this is a long story I brought the guy
up and it's credit I go what are your
credits and his credits were that he's
performed in almost all 50 states and I
was like well that could be everybody's
credit but almost like it was not I
performed in yeah it was like I'm almost
once done all 50 states so that's some
and the crowd was like whoa yeah he
never said how many either I could have
been 10 you could have been 4933 he
almost almost
I'm on my way did he start his set with
material about this did he just run
through a mic let's talk about Arizona's
go let me tell you where I've been there
it was very loose it have been benefit
event like wish your credits man can you
just tell people the only places that I
haven't been is Rhode Island and Montana
thanks man yeah he's only not before I
could see your recent back wait which
states you haven't been that have you
any gigs where you just cut them short
like we just say [ __ ] this amount
you do I think pretty regularly no I
think I've always I mean maybe I would
like got offers but I've never like been
like I'm not doing this there's no like
and I've done bad I've done the show the
college they called me a nooner and the
guy walked in you had to find the stage
and there's just in the cafeteria people
are just eating it's like 18 year olds
and like 45 year old people because it's
a community college and they're and the
guy walks up and I was showed up minute
late I was there at 12:01 that shows me
at 12:00 he goes you're late I was like
what's only a minute and then he goes
I'll be back in an hour just get me the
microphone and walked away and then I
had to go like just into a room that
doesn't even know there's a show gonna
start oh [ __ ] did you introduce yourself
I brought someone that was outside
Chicago flew to Chicago and I brought
someone those in Chicago and and he been
but he went up and he I made him go up
and then II went over he Britt he cut he
cut very early on his time because he
was real bad and then and then I went up
and then I mean I'm just doing my act to
like nothing it's worse than doing your
actress in your room by yourself huh
you're just doing this no reaction
nothing you start getting teary you just
in the cafeteria people eating out here
watching people like answer the phone
watching people hug I haven't seen you
know what I mean they're having like
that [ __ ] like their life is still
moving and I could initially there's
probably 100 people there in that room
that would never know they were at one
of my shows that I could go and like
you've been at my shuffelin they're like
I have Noah I have no recollection of a
show going on you ever do one in a new
name is like County cafeteria kind of
lounge area and so much trying to map
and you start going up and they look
back at you at no wait like can you see
I'm trying to sleep in his business like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
[Laughter]
[Music]
some relatives asleep
I've seen people sleep where I'm like
you gotta talk to letter if they sleep
then have that person be awake right I
love when actually wanna sleep when
somebody sleeping in one of the first
few rows oh this is perfect that gets a
do ten minutes there's not scripted
because I white ice so it's tough to
sleep in a in a show I just wonder what
they might you know yeah they'd be
distracted greg Giraldo is special he
has someone asleep in the and I'm pretty
sure there is asleep something happens
with someone I think they're asleep and
then he goes off and they put they left
it in this special because it's very
funny like but just be like is this not
enough like a special like it's not
we're gonna give you a regular Friday
night being at a live show that's still
insane but we'll give you that right
Comedy Central hours special what was
this person seated pretty close
like not deep you know probably five six
rows deep kind of Mayberry's they're
always up front the one the problems are
always in the front the the people that
are problems wanna go they're like but
how would they know that we're gonna
mess the show up if we're in the back
and you're like yeah no and they're like
we should be up front I often see I
often see it's like it's usually the
scenarios it's a couple and usually the
fan is the guy yeah too many drinks keep
it together but it's like it's like the
heroin not off
just watch them go yeah get it together
yeah fall asleep out a special is is
pretty bad because those are really well
lit yeah this guy was lit yeah yeah and
there's carried lights cameras got the
guy getting the reaction shots
I fell asleep though to bed out of it
was a drinking sleep and uh I'd like an
IndyCar race what that is yeah the
drivers were furious this guy as they
flew by me
and I'm that way those are the ones you
start drinking it like 4:00 in the
morning you wake up and start drinking
at 4:00 or 5:00 in the morning because
it's like a NASCAR like and then it was
when I lived in Chicago and there and
then we get there and it's like 10:00
a.m. we've already been drinking all day
and drinking with like guys that go to
these this stuff all the time so they're
just like this is what they do for a.m.
star drink I mean I want to say some
guys will 4:00 a.m. and they don't wake
up to go some will be 5 a.m. like 6 a.m.
but yeah they get you start tailgating
and you start like getting it getting it
going you kind of person they could day
drink and then make it to the evening
without taking a nap it's a pro you're a
problem person yes I see that we like
talked to a group at one point and say I
sure AM neighbor gets him an alcoholic
you will eventually the Sun Goes Down
like that day drinking drunkenness just
turns into just body's got to shut down
we got to reset it's not fun it's
terrible yeah you you said you stopped
drinking you haven't drink come on st.
couple months yeah how's it been gone
good you know it's better we as you we
you know we've drank a bunch and it's
just time times you like I'm getting
older I just turned 39 so I'm like
you're your body's like it's I'm
starting to you start filling everything
yeah
you're like ah this is not I used to eat
I mean I still eat pretty bad but like
fast foods like something like I love
fast food and it's brutal like it just
hurts it does so you know that's just
fun stuff this is good stuff that I
think has all been covered within comedy
in the past 40 years fast food you
turned 40
because people always ask why it's you
stop drinking and it's I I did it I did
it
I put I put some numbers on the board
yeah comedy nights deaf people don't
because it's like when you go every town
you go to they think it's like oh let's
go drinking and you're like I go out
every weekend so I like so whatever your
did to you you're like I'm gonna drink
tonight and then we're be normal people
for until hannibal comes back but like
you're still hannibal every single time
so you're just gonna be drinking in so
we multiply in in new york new york
there's no rules dude they stay open
till 6:00 in them they stay open till
whenever you want to go home and then
there's a magical train that takes you
home you don't have to drop like or you
just get in our car and go i want to go
here and he get you there it's in
there's no it's like there's no one
there being like hey you got to chill
out like so and you're just all in here
when you first move York when I first
moved there to like everybody was
stopping drinking that's what you the
older comics all stop and then so then
you're like sitting there what are we
gonna who we gonna drink with you know
and then you find your new guys I mean I
drink with a towel night after a couple
nights but he stopped drinking now but
he was a fun one but he's a guy that
could go on all day and just drinking
like you would just go out with him and
he's just you buy everybody drinks and
then he just leaves doesn't tell you buy
doesn't tell you anything and you're
just sitting there you know and you're
like you're like where's the Toa he's
just gone you know like all right I I
still go out a decent amount night drink
you know I put myself in situations to
test my sobriety
I'll go to comedy over mics with Terrell
I went to one in Hawaii it was bad
comedians and I was like if I don't
drink here I'm really strong yeah and
went to the strip club in Atlanta a
couple weeks ago sober and I still
enjoyed myself in a strip club but I was
still like yo dis [ __ ] is weird as [ __ ]
this place exists we've been weird
painful but that's definitely a place
you have the drink is a strip club but
it took me it took me a while to just
even because I wanted you got a tip and
[ __ ] and is is throwing money is a drunk
man's game yeah absolutely
that's why I'm saying then just having
money and throwing it just rollin truck
man's game at there willing to be
inebriated where that's fun yeah it took
me a while I had to kind of mentally to
prep myself and say you know just you
know throw you know 80 bucks or so
you're supporting the arts oh [ __ ] man
so I order a ginger ale
and I get I get a couple hundred bucks
it was from the bartender and I get I
give her the ginger Ale's five bucks
which is a hoax and I give her $6 for
the ginger ale
five bucks plus one dollar 20% tip one
dollar per drink very silent standard
stuff and she says you only gonna tip
that much you got a couple hundred ones
I said you shut your pocket watching ass
up what the hell this got to do with
this situation over there so goddamn
gingery on his five bucks
I fired the wrong sample I do have the
away hold on
I do have these yeah yeah a nate is a
Nate theremin solo alright let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wow yeah as inspiring my man hey Nick
barks Ari it's sorry to cut it off like
that I was trying to do a xanthines like
rap samples and subject focus man yeah
yeah didn't work out but you telling me
about you list it you heard a trend well
you just heard a few rappers talking
about the same thing and it was weird
well the thing is I've talked to several
women about like douching like like I
don't feel like the dust deucing douche
like the douche but like when you clean
like the feminine hygiene it's like oh
like the hot water bottle Duchenne I
don't even exactly know what it is but I
know that you call somebody an [ __ ] a
douche bag so right that's hot water
bottle okay so whatever it is I feel
like I feel I feel like rappers are
experts about it because I hear it a lot
in rap song yeah we're talking about
douchey
so here I got some examples here's one
[Music]
zoic and so there's one that was very
descriptive very descriptive like he
could be a gynecologist with that yeah
cuz he that was like three that was a
three-tier disc even even had a poor in
summer so as hey I need to distance
blown again does that smell like step
back
yeah which I've never heard step back
used like that except for I'm talking
about basketball jumpers
okay so then James Harden yeah so that
was a that was Mannie Fresh
[Music]
I heard douche was scope did I know that
mouthwash scope
this was stove that that's painful so he
wants his [ __ ] this was a windy
that's like me masturbate with hand
sanitizer exactly so I got I got more he
doesn't even want to hit but he wants to
make sure that it's clean
he's gonna make sure it doesn't stick
around to your ass getting the shower
that I'm out then I'm adding in a lift
so high now I'm leaving in a lift line
over boo baby [ __ ] [ __ ] clean yourself
when I leave in a toy y'all to free us
why is he he's so concerned but I don't
think that's now y'all clean yourselves
like that rid of it it's like 35 and I
been in this game for years
he's just puzzling this guy you guys
have heard of a rapper named bust down
he's an old for Betsy nobody knows who
yeah oh yeah he was known for just
making really explicit tracks from back
in the days I think he was like real
early 90s and then he had this one
[Music]
[Music]
very see very descriptive stuff sour
cream and onion that's a chip flavor Wow
so you know I you know what I wonder
what originated it was because I feel
like it's just like anything where
somebody started off doing it and then
other rappers said this is what we're
talking about
gosh I just I guess maybe this is the
easy ride yeah it does push push push
trust us if you're
[Music]
and
[Music]
see cause here's the thing that smell
like mush mush like it's much smell like
I thought that was a bush is most like
gruel like orphans eat these most was
most like hummus yeah porridge right
porch I don't know man
smelt like mush what does mush smell
like I think mush is just just a sum
that you can't quite recognize just a
bunch of [ __ ] cobble together and it's
like what is this mush
yeah but the smell of mush it's like a
mush to me is like a onomatopoeia like
wow bush yes I guess it depends on who's
making the mush you know yeah howdy
I give Rachel right made some mush mush
in there today I'm making mush in 30
minutes or less I mean that what
Gretchen says basically is a grits
[ __ ] no grits you got upset I didn't
get upset it was just terrible thing I'm
sure of
grits net being much I forget what grits
grits our days are ground corn whoo do
people still [ __ ] with how many yeah
Prince
it's a family kind of shape though how
many is the sake grits is harmony is
awful it's corn it's like it looks like
corn nuts it's like it's like in the the
pozole
that's like main gird ingredient in the
pozole it's delicious you see you can't
you tell can't you tell what did you
just tell when he talked about food how
he changes a little bit
I love I mean I'm passionate about food
tell them I'm good I just assumed I just
like to take for granted that women
sometimes have a bad day at the office
that's how I look at it I'm never like
you got a douche I'm just like all right
this is this isn't the time this isn't
your day and I mean I don't say anything
but that's why I give little I get a
little verbal I start
the navel and then she knows no women
should make rap songs about guys have a
smelly dicks oh my balls are the worse
well you got that bad summer day where
your balls are not smelling fresh you
don't have you don't have bad boy
quality I wash up man what's up before
she gets down now I know they wash you
down there I give her neck massage you
also make sweet love in 3 p.m. now cell
look at me
[Music]
to be mad at 3:09
[Music]
that's the whole song Oh Flo you guys
know you got yeah ooh
you get it I don't think so young uns
get off it use it the whole time we have
been hey we got any whiff about the
close the show down and we'll appreciate
you guys coming thanks a lot it's been
fun kind of what you didn't wrap once
this whole episode what time hold on
time we were just talking about you how
many tracks you dropped how many tracks
with you drop how many tracks of I Drive
I get gibberish rap yep I get a Versace
breakfast I get old [ __ ] with gene grant
quail egg Chris I get did his rabbit in
North Korea I got that trap you got that
track I'm late cuz he was uh it was
Flying Lotus on the beat when I was at
Flying Lotus house and I say hey man
play me a beat there's not like any of
your other beats that's not and he just
like got on a computer for a while he
played me this I was a little high as I
got to studio and I got on the mic and
knocked it out of once cuz he was one he
was this is about four years ago four or
five I love this track it's great with
Dennis Robert so I was trying to is a
song exclusive you ever go crazy
going crazy now let you come you know we
call it come go with this rapid and look
three yeah that mean you crazy
[Music]
his beat as hot as [ __ ]
[Music]
look
[Music]
by a bottle by bottle my bottle get
surprised by the fail real
oh it is robbing out North Korea
[Music]
yeah good song yeah we got in the
artists in a crowd
nobody spit can anybody spit bars out
here
yeah yeah you can write when I got your
handle blink you can write now don't I
go
[Music]
she's just signed a high-five people
she's big
I thought you're appointed just off the
route you come up here a rap if you want
[Music]
man like you got a fear you can start a
say to people's eyes when they could
spit she's here supporting us but she
ain't got no bars I don't I don't judge
the book by its cover
you know she handle bars it's okay to
Matt bars but she was she was just
trying to hide what other people she was
it's like she's like yeah and she was
just doing this like and she's looking
back she looked back for help
[Music]
yeah I'm playing yellow confidence yes
Kat bar talk about my goddamn cell phone
signal zanuck
[Music]
all right well this is a fun time you
guys Nashville give it up for Tony trim
one more time
Kevin Bozeman Nate bargatze
I'm Hannibal Burres thanks for talking
as recorded thank you the Third Man
Records
yeah then we'll see you it to get second
settle say these shows
good night Mary Ellen
[Applause]
[Music]